the cabinet now tweeting their support  they are liz trust saying the prime  minister has my 100 backing in today's  vote and i strongly encourage colleagues  to support him he has delivered on covid  recovery and supporting ukraine in the  face of russian aggression he has  apologized for mistakes made we must now  focus on economic growth that's what we  always hear isn't it indeed and other  conservative mps have also started  tweeting their support for the prime  minister the to try and uh to try and  rally colleagues to that i've seen i've  seen a few four or five now conservative  back benches tweeting their support